should know that matters be
the moment we're living in right now
no
hi this is joshua corman josh corman
sounds sort of like joseph gordon
he's not me and i started imagining what
my life could have been like
so what do you do i teach fifth grade
shut up i love you having him be a
teacher was
something that i've always kind of
wanted to do and the story of mr corman
is
what if some things had turned out a
little different in my life
punch buggy david you've always had
something against david i don't have
anything against david he's just a bad
person
seven yeah but you can be a bad person
when you're seven
josh had certain ideas about what he
thought his life was gonna be like
as he arrived in adulthood that haven't
panned out
and he's kind of wrestling with that
well i wouldn't have agreed to go on a
date with
an actual musician right well then
i'm your guy what i was trying to do
when i was writing the show was just
trying to be honest and
and true and real yeah
that's universal we're all trying to
figure out who we are where we fit
what's bothering you
every thought that i have i'm like did i
lock my car should i go
check but what if i trip on my way to
check so then should i just leave my car
unlocked well
we went i think we went too narrow on
that one even like the saddest moments
have a bit of
comedy to it and i don't think this show
shies away from that
that's not funny obviously it is come on
that's why it strikes me as so
real and genuine josh is someone who
just
loves his creativity and you know his
music
music is an important theme all the way
through because it's something that
josh really cares about and ultimately i
suppose walked away from
from dark times comes great art as they
say
do they say that play back one more time
i have created the show you could say i
wrote it and directed it
great yeah but definitely took a whole
bunch of other incredibly talented
artists to make it
it wasn't just me one of the things that
is so special about working with joe is
that he has a huge amount of respect for
everyone around him movie making is
ultimately collaborative and the more
collaborators
i brought in the better the show got
[Music]
i have it really good it just it doesn't
always
feel that way i guess well the fault is
that
thanks mom
you